♪ ♪
>> Hannity: MORE VOTERS
CELERON AS JOB PERFORMANCE NEW
ISSUES AND INSIDE POLL RELEASED
TODAY FOUND THAT ONLY 19% OF
VOTERS SURVEYED CHOSE A
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN AS THE
PREFERRED DEMOCRATIC NOMINEE IN
2,024 BY THE WAY THEY PUT HIM
NEARLY TEN POINTS BEHIND I'M NOT
SURE, MEANWHILE MORE RECENT
STUDIES AND SURVEYS SHOW THAT HE
IS LOSING GROUND WITH KEY
DEMOGRAPHICS THAT HELPED ELECT
HIM IN THE FIRST PLACE
PARTICULARLY SUBURBAN VOTERS
WHEN MPR POLL CONDUCTED IN
FEBRUARY FOUND HIS APPROVAL
AMONG SUBURBAN VOTERS WHO
DROPPED FROM OVER TEN POINTS
FROM THE END OF 2,021 A 12-POINT
DROP AMONG SUBURBAN WOMEN HIS
APPROVAL WITH YOUNG VOTERS ONE
OF THE STRONGEST GROUPS IN THE
2,020 ELECTION THAT'S A MYSTERY
TO ME.
NOW SITS IN A NEAR 41% AND
DESPITE THE ABYSMAL POLL NUMBERS
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF DID A
PRETTY BIZARRE VICTORY LAP AFTER
THE FRENCH PRESIDENT REELECTION
THIS WEEKEND DESPITE THEIR
SERVED 36% APPROVAL RATING
SEEMINGLY IMPLYING THAT
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN CAN WIN IN
2,024 WITH A POLL OF 33%
ANYWHERE HERE WAS HIS REACTION
OUTNUMBERED AND THE AUTHOR OF
THE SOON TO BE RELEASED
SUPPRESSION DECEPTION SNOBBERY
AND BIAS WHY THE PRESS GETS SO
MUCH WRONG AND JUST DOES NOT
CARE.
BY THE WEEK THAT FIRST EDITION
COPY ON Amazon.com OR
Hannity.com FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR IS WITH US KAYLEE
LET ME START WITH YOU.
IT'S EVERY DEMOGRAPHIC AND
DEPENDENCIES DOWN TO 26%
HISPANIC AMERICANS DOWN 26% HE'S
DOWN WITH SUBURBAN VOTERS,
AFRICAN-AMERICANS THE YOUTH
VOTE, EVERY SINGLE DEMOGRAPHIC
IS DOWN DRAMATICALLY AND I'M
LOOKING AT THE POLICIES HE
PUTTING IN PLACE AND I DON'T SEE
ANY MOVEMENT AT ALL TOWARDS
MAKING THE ADJUSTMENTS THAT ONE
MIGHT MAKE IF THEY WANT TO TURN
THINGS AROUND.
>> NO, HE'S TAKEN THE ADVICE OF
SENATOR WARREN WHO SAYS HE NEEDS
A DOUBLE DOWN THESE PROGRESSIVE
POLICIES AND MAKE GOOD ON THEM
IS NOT THE ANSWER SEAN.
BUT THE REASON HE'S DOING THIS
KIND OF ALL OF BRANCH ON
STUDENT LOANS, THE ROLLING BACK
OF TITLE 42, THERE'S SOME
REPORTING THAT ALL MAY BE HE'S
NOT CAN ROLL IT BACK.
HE ALWAYS WAS.
IF THERE'S A PROBLEM SEAN HE'S
LOSING THE AOC LEAD OF THE
PARTY, HE HAS TO KEEP THEM SO HE
DOESN'T HAVE TIME TO TRY TO
ESTABLISH HIS INDEPENDENT
SUBURBAN MOMS BECAUSE WHAT IS
HAVING TO DO IS APPEASE THE
RADICAL LEFT AND SEAN I JUST
HAVE TO SAY THAT THAT CHIEF OF
STAFF TWEET HE SEVERELY
DELUSIONAL BUT THOSE ARE THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT JOE BIDEN
IS HEARING THE OVAL OFFICE HIS
ADVISORS, HIS MAIN YEARS ARE
SAYING YOU'RE DOING GREAT DON'T
LISTEN TO WHAT THEY'RE SAYING I
DON'T CABLE KNOWS.
YOUR WINNING MR. PRESIDENT IS AN
ECHO CHAMBER OF BLISS AND
EUPHORIA THAT SIBLEY DOES NOT
EXIST.
>> Hannity: WILL RESPECTED
DEMOCRATIC POSTER THESE ECONOMIC
BLOWS ARE NOT JUST ONE ELEMENT
IN A CASCADING SET OF PROBLEMS
ALL COMING AT THE SAME TIME
COMBINES A NUCLEAR ANXIETIES OF
THE 50s AND 60s WITH THE
INFLATION THIRD OF THE 70s THE
CRIME WAVE IN THE 80s AND
90s AND THE TENSIONS OVER
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IN THE
2000s AND BEYOND THEN HE SAYS
THIS.
THIS IS NOT EXPERIENCING LISA'S
JIMMY CARTER ONCE SAID TO
PROCLAIM BUT INSTEAD FORMED A
DEEP NATIONAL FISSURE READY TO
BLOW LIKE A GEYSER THE NEXT
ELECTION IF THE LEADERSHIP DOES
NOT MOVE WILL RELIEVE THE
PRESSURE.
NOW AS A DEMOCRATIC POSTER
THAT'S A PRETTY DEEP PROFOUND
PREDICTION ON HIS PART AND I
AGREE WITH EVERY WORD OF IT.
>> IT'S VERY IN TOUCH WITH THE
MAN ON THE STREET.
THE WOMAN ON THE STREET ALL
THESE YEARS NOW WERE JUST FED UP
WITH EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING ON
NOTHING'S GOING BETTER AND THEN
JOE BIDEN CAME ALONG AND MADE
ALL THESE PROMISES FUMBLED, AND
FUMBLED THROUGH EVERYTHING.
LUKE LET ME BREAK DOWN THE
NUMBERS ARE TWO DIFFERENT WAYS
FOR 2,022 THE MIDTERM ELECTION
NOTHING WAS IN A CHANGE IT.
HISTORICAL TIDE AGAINST PARTIES
IN THE FIRST TERM OF A
PRESIDENCY COMBINED WITH ALL OF
HIS PROBLEMS IN THE NATION'S
PROBLEMS IT'S ALREADY THE KISS
OF DEATH BY THE DEMOCRATS.
HISTORY TELLS US THAT PRESIDENTS
WHO LOSE AND GET CLOBBERED THE
MIDTERM CAN'T COME BACK AS
BILL CLINTON DID AND
BARACK OBAMA DID.
BUT JOE BIDEN CANTS.
AND THE REASON SEAN I SAY THAT
WITH SUCH ASSURANCE IS OF THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY IS NOT CAN WANT
80-YEAR-OLD IN DECLINE TO LEAD
THE PARTY PARTICULARLY AFTER
THEY LOSE THE HOUSE AND THE
SENATE AND WHEN HE SAW HIM
UNPOPULAR.
EVEN IF THINGS TURN AROUND TWO
YEARS IN THE ECONOMY SEEMS TO
GET STRONG THINGS CHANGE
JOE BIDEN WILL NOT BE AT THE
HELM OF THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY IT
JUST WILL NOT HAPPEN.
>> Hannity: IF YOU LOOK AT
"THE WASHINGTON POST" LAST WEEK
KAYLEE THEY HAD JOE BIDEN ONE A
FEE IS THE LEAD.
THE REPEAT WHO PETE BUTTIGIEG
AHEAD OF KAMALA HARRIS AND THEN
A LIST OF PEOPLE THAT I DON'T
THINK INSPIRE CONFIDENCE IN
ANYBODY BUT I THINK THE ONE
THING THAT MAKES ARTERIES
PREDICTION CORRECT MORE THAN ONE
THING IS THE FACT THAT THERE ARE
INCAPABLE OF GIVING INTO THE
RADICAL BASE AND SAYING
SOMETHING LIKE BILL CLINTON SO
THE ERROR OF BIG GOVERNMENT IS
OVER AND END OF WELFARE AS WE
KNOW IT.
THAT DOESN'T EXIST WITHIN THIS
RADICAL PARTY.
>> NO THAT'S A BYGONE ERA EVEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA KNEW WHEN TO
SPEAK UP FOR HIMSELF AT SOME
POINT DISAGREE WITH THEM
ENTIRELY BUT HOWEVER BY AT LEAST
SOME ISSUES HE KNEW THAT WE
NEEDED TO TRACK A LITTLE BIT
TOWARDS THE MIDDLE THAT'S GONE
THOUGH.
YOU'RE DEAFLY RIGHT THAT WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THAT TRACKER IS VERY
INTERESTING SEAN THE REPORTING
THAT IN THE WEST WING THERE'S
WHISPERS, COMMON LAW IS DONE
PEOPLE WHO JUDGES THE GUY WERE
LOOKING TO BUT WHAT I'M
INTERESTED IN AS I THAT YOU PUT
UP SEAN THAT NOT SURE IS MORE
POPULAR THEN JOE BIDEN IS
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS DID
NOT SCORE.
THERE IS NO BENCH OF THIS PARTY
SEAN LOOK AT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY YOUR STANDARD-BEARER PAIR
RESIDENTS.
HE ALSO A HUGE DEEP AMOUNT OF
PEOPLE RON DeSANTIS IF SOME
DEGREE PEOPLE THEY HAVE NOT SURE
THAT'S WHO THEY HAVE.
>> Hannity: LET'S SEE IF
DONALD TRUMP DECIDED TO RUN
EVERY SINGLE DAY WITH EVERY FILL
POLICY AND EVERY BAD DECISION
THAT JOE BIDEN MAKES THAT HIS
HANNITY KEYS BACK TO
DONALD TRUMP.
IF I WAS DONALD TRUMP I MOSTLY
LIKE JOE BIDEN I DO MY RALLIES I
WOULD DO INTERVIEWS WITH
NONHOSTILE MEDIA WAGON INTO A
FIGHT WITH MEDIA THAT HATES YOUR
GUTS.
IT DOESN'T SEEM TO MATTER I
WOULD PROSECUTE THE CASE VERSUS
JOE HOW BAD HIS POLICIES ARE
REMIND PEOPLE WHAT HE DID TELL
PEOPLE HOUSING TO GET US OUT OF
THE MESS THAT JOE CREATED AND
SAY GOD BLESS YOU, GOD BLESS
AMERICA AND GOOD NIGHT.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD ALSO BEAR
IN MIND HOW SUCCESSFUL AMERICA
WAS UNDER
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP'S
POLICIES PARTICULARLY FOR CHILD
POVERTY RATES ON APPOINTMENT
DATES AND FOR HISPANICS.
SO MANY ECONOMIC INDICATORS
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT FOR YEARS THAT
IF ALL PEOPLE FROM THE BOTTOM
RISE UP THERE ALL KICKING INTO
HIGH GEAR AND THEN COVID HIT.
IT'S A HUGE SUCCESS STORY THE
ISSUES THAT THEY HAVING ITS
DONALD TRUMP IS THAT THEY LOVE
TO HATE THEM.
SO THEY GET A BOOST AND TURN UP
IF DONALD TRUMP IS THAT GETS ANY
OTHER CANDIDATE.
BUT I'LL THINK IT REALLY MATTERS
FOR JOE BIDEN.
NONE OF THAT PLAYS INTO IT.
I THINK JOE BIDEN IT'S
INEVITABLE SEAN FOR AN EARLY
2,023 SHORTLY AFTER THE MID TURN
SHELLACKING HE'S GOING TO
SUCCUMB TO THE PRESSURE THAT'S
BUILT UP INSIDE THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND ANNOUNCED
THAT HE IS NOT RUNNING FOR
REELECTION.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE CHOMPING AT
THE BITS TO GET OUT OF THE
STARTING GATES RIGHT AFTER THE
NOVEMBER ELECTION.
THIS IS JUST SIX MONTHS FROM NOW
A LITTLE OVER SIX MONTHS FROM
NOW.
THIS COULD BE UPON US REAL SOON.
>> Hannity: I DON'T KNOW IF
POLLS INDICATE THEIR NOT SURE IF
YOU'LL EVEN FINISH THE FIRST
TERM AND IDEA OF A SECOND TERM I
WAS NOT BUYIN